all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show we just saw a great clip of the
film fighting with my family about WWE
Superstar page that opens nationwide
today the writer/director and a man
whose acting in the film fighting with
my family Stephen Merchant good to see
you thank you so much I am a big fan of
yours oh great and I don't usually start
interviews that way but I feel like
that's it I might as well leave now yes
your brother that's a walk I've been a
big fan of yours obviously since the the
office came across the Atlantic here at
the UK office so thank you for thank you
for being here why are why'd you do this
movie why we are you a super are you
with a wrestling fan ever
prior to this scene any wrestling never
watched Reza well a Saab sure I watched
a little bit of British wrestling with
my grandfather in the 70s if you've
never seen from the 70s if your image of
wrestling is people like Dwayne Johnson
and Stone Cold Steve Austin ripped guys
doing backflips British wrestling in the
70s was really overweight men just sort
of flapping their bellies against one
another they had names like Big Daddy
there was a guy called giant haystacks
because if there's one thing that
strikes fear it's hay and this was so
popular on British TV in the 70s
and-and-and there was nothing athletic
about it and I mean it was really but we
have very low expectations for
entertainment in the 70s and so that was
my knowledge of wrestling there's big -
very nice hat we had Lena Headey in this
week that's the only ones I remember and
they were on a show called world of
sport which seemed a bit rich I mean
they've got the physiques of darts
players and and so that was all over so
and even as a kid I was like what is
this I didn't understand whether a sport
or entertainment had no idea and so when
this project came along I mean I guess I
had a vague idea of people like Hulk
Hogan in the 80s but I never watched
WWE and so this documentary got sent to
me by Dwayne Johnson about this family
of British wrestlers and I sort of sat
down if I'm honest slightly reluctantly
thinking
I'll watch it because the rock is sent
in to mean you do what the rock tells
you yeah and I just fell in love with
this family and so charmed by them and
there they all wrestle mum dad three
kids the dream is to get the kids into
WWE which is obviously the big leagues
they're just playing too sore to bit you
know venues in and around small towns in
England and the brother didn't get
signed page the daughter did and she
went off to America a young age to kind
of train with WWE and sort of carrying
the way of the family dream and her own
dreams with her and it's just this great
kind of Rocky style true life underdog
story so how did you get hooked up with
Dwayne Johnson I mean it well thank you
for asking is there a history in that
regard I have known Dwayne for about 10
years I knew Dwayne when he was still in
shape movie with him called tooth fairy
you're welcome and we stayed in touch
over the years and we and we sort of had
a good rapport I think doing that movie
yes and he like I say he saw this
documentary about this family and became
involved with their lives and I think
along the way realized it would make a
good feature and I'm fairly sure Dwayne
only knows two British people me and
Jason Statham and he goes to stay them
for you know what he needs a smaller guy
that he can pretend to be up on camera
yeah and he comes to me if he needs
someone to write something and and so we
started working on the project so you're
that go to Ghana Kosuke for him well you
know Statham can do you know 60 sit-ups
in 30 seconds but I can do 40 words a
minute on the word processor he's more
he's more of the Guy Ritchie guy in the
relationship exactly is that he's in
those movies you know Lock Stock and but
for you that the light-hearted comedy
that's the guy you come to be uplifting
the uplifting story of Brits turning
young lady into superstars
internationals I'm your man you're the
guy got a script for you yeah no I don't
actually have a script but uh it's it's
so much fun and like we said we had Lena
Headey and yet earlier this week and
yeah her scenes she's not in any scenes
with Iraq obviously she's part of the
family in which the fighting is taking
place yeah
and so when it all come
down to it are you now a wrestling fan I
went to Wrestlemania with Dwayne and
that was I call him Dwayne and that was
eye-opening because that was a hundred
thousand people it was in Dallas and you
know the Crowder electric and then when
you see these guys and these women just
actually at work in the ring and you see
this this combination of the athleticism
and the stunt work and the showmanship
and the performance and the choreography
it's really really entertaining it's
it's it's it's enormous ly thrilling to
watch and I you know I really had to
immerse myself in the wrestling world to
understand this movie and you know I
went and I went to matches and I went to
the training facility and my respect for
them has really gone through the roof is
what is it like going to Wrestlemania
with Dwayne Johnson that Elvis is in the
building it's unbelievable it's
extraordinary the guy walked out on
stage with a flamethrower and set fire
to a eight foot sign of his name and he
milked that for ten minutes before he
said words we walk to the left flame or
the right flame you know and it was and
they did not stop screaming and cheering
for that guy the whole time cuz he you
know let you say it's like Elvis has
come back when they see him it's I've
never known anyone with that sense of
charisma and that ability to so just
work a crowd but it actually worked in
our detriment because we had this big
scene in the movie and we shot it we had
one hour and after a WWE telecast on a
Monday Night Raw at the Staples Center
and they said we will keep the fans back
and we only had an hour and I said to
Dwayne you know who's gonna come down
he's gonna kind of emcee the event I
said please don't get carried away we've
only got an hour guy goes out there in
front of the fans did 20 minutes on the
mic no he's making phone calls he's
doing selfies he's doing the
catchphrases can you smell I'm like you
know starts up in the stands thinking
yeah we can smell what you're cooking
may get the ring but he was amazing cuz
he just he just played that crowd like
an orchestra and was just so perfect for
us to be able to get the shots we needed
he's extraordinary fighting with my
family again theaters nationwide right
now I'm speaking with the writer and
director Stephen Merchant you also
act in the film I have to ask you about
the office if you don't mind worse how
how did it come about with you and ricky
gervais creating the office when did how
did you come up with the idea well we
were together at a radio station uh he
was my boss essentially and um what's he
like David Brent not at all because um
well he was even lazier than they say he
did very little work I'm fairly sure any
reason I got hired by him was because my
resume was on the top of the pile okay
and he couldn't be bothered to work
through the others he calls me in and we
hit it off and we would you know just
joke and riff about observations of
office life I realized he was gonna get
me fired so I jumped ship during the BBC
and while I was there I do portunity to
make a little training video and I
called Ricky and I said let's do the the
office stuff we did and we made this
little tape and and it just came alive
Ricky's performance was electric the
observations felt fresh and kind of
authentic and it just began to snowball
from there although they the BBC did a
test screening of the first episode of
The Office the British version and it
scored the lowest audience score ever my
only thing that was lower was women's
lawn bowls which is sort of like you
know like bocce okay or something but
but and so the that was the only thing
that was considered more boring than the
office but you know they stuck with it
anyway and and here we go thank I mean
what a what a juggernaut it has turned
into so did you or Ricky Gervais ever
have a boss that basically wanted to be
popular rather than actually efficient
and a leader like did you ever have
somebody like that we once thought we'd
both worked in completely different
places and and and we just said what
would work for the similar kind of guys
and even when we were working at the BBC
you know you people would say no one's
like this and you'd walk around the BBC
like here's one right here you know I
mean they're they're everywhere really
um
I don't care what job you're doing I
don't care if you're working you know
for NASA or you know you're in the mob I
think there's the same kind of these
same kind of people and that's just the
way you shot it it's now so many
different shows
have sampled I wish I could get a couple
those right cats of all those shows
where they just zoom in on a mock
documentary or someone just looks in the
lens where did you pick that one up from
where did you did you we're even smarter
we shot at documentary style cuz it
seemed like just a quickest way to shoot
you know we didn't have to do lots of
clever lighting we could kind of move
fast right and at the time in England
there were there was a real spate of
these kind of fly-on-the-wall
documentaries where people regular
people were becoming celebrities off the
back of these shows there's one about
driving school there was one about
cruise ship so it's kind of in the air
you know and so I think we kind of
wanted to satirize that and play with
that idea like you say it's everyone
does it no it's it's it's like dear
eager to do something like that right
now
yeah is there ever a what's the your
favorite office moment that hit the
cutting room floor that you could not
put on the air for some reason or never
made it on the air well I remember we
used to cut things out because we were
trying to keep a tone that felt
authentic and real and anything that
kind of veered too much felt too silly
right or too crazy but Ricky does a in
the British version does this Dan this
became a kind of iconic moment and I I
had to persuade him to let me include
that because he was like it seems too
crazy no one's gonna buy it so that
almost hit the cutting room floor and I
had to fight him to keep well well done
Stephen Merchant
well done who's your favorite character
from the American version Wow I don't
know I mean I had to say I I you know
what was exciting about going to see
those guys at work is it was like it was
like we've created a show in England and
then like amazing talent that kind of
just taken it and we're running with the
ball I mean you could go down there and
see Steve Carell that guy can improvise
stuff funnier than you can ever write
you know it was kind of so exciting to
watch him at work I I just um I loved
that show largely because it pays for my
house that's right so you'd want to
choose one I can't choose a particular
individual you know because I'll just
upset the others you will you know it's
amazing how popular it has become it's
crazy with like younger teenagers who I
guess haven't even worked in an office
well because you know we all know people
who are just basically putting
a whole bunch of BS right and skating
through right into a position of power
yeah over people who know this is a con
I mean we all have been in situations
but also you know it makes no difference
it's like you put these shows on the air
you you you you highlight these kind of
people and and I mean I'd be walking
with Ricky Gervais and people would come
up to me like hey you know that boss you
play I'm just like that good I need to
say it like a badge of honor you know
you know that's not good have you gotten
into any American sports in any way
shape or form or it I like to go to
basketball games because I'm six foot
seven and I feel I'm among my people
okay you ever netball do you ever do the
netball a little bit of basketball okay
it turns out I have no hand to eye
coordination whatsoever so you never got
into that played a little bit of cricket
but was always remember the day one of
going to play cricket as I was leaving
the house my mother said be careful
because there was a boy in my school and
he took a cricket ball in the head and
II got brain damage send me off and I
just was petrified the whole time and
then the the seasons changed in rugby
season began same thing again I'm
leaving my mother because we did today
playing rugby all be careful boy in my
school I broke his neck playing rugby ah
geez and so I never thought you found
the right spot for yourself is it true
last one for you Stephen Merchant that
you attended the Patriots victory parade
is that a true story
I've been doing a promotional tour for
this movie and I've been flying around
and it seems like I'm kind of following
the news cycle I landed in Chicago as
the polar vortex descended I think we
were on the same flight and and then
yeah a few days later I find myself I
come at my hotel room and I'm right on
the parade route of the of the
celebration yeah so they are marching
right past my bedroom I can't get any
sleep they keep me awake oh I was
furious this timing sucks yeah so you
just went out and you joined it though
right I just yeah I took off my shirt
painted my face in the colour stares at
the parade hey congrats on this film
fighting with my family it is so much
fun and it's been fun meeting you please
come back any time I really appreciate
having again a big fan of everything
that you put out there Stephen Merchant
at Stephen Merchant with a pee
H on Twitter and also on Instagram and
check out fighting with my family opens
nationwide to day the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience